en clair qu les dragons mais non écoutés
d'accord mais trader ait pu se mettre en
règle ce jeu vous je vous prends quel a
été le résultat nombre de cette audience
je ne peux résoudre ohlala je ne veux
vraiment il ya vous ayez une bousculade
finalement je ne fais pas nous serons ça
au mois de décembre 13 décembre et nous
aurons le jugement seulement le 13
décembre
mademoiselle else i meyer et moi même
maître et le 6 mai hier et moi même
comme notre client johnny hallyday dans
l'impatience de savoir ce qu'il reste se
passe et obtient expliquant nous
maintenant bon finalement pour vous
quelle impression cette audience on vous
a fait la morale et sa bonne forme de
morale c'est exact en vous disant qu'il
fallait que soyez senti responsable leur
valse la route de le faire c'est le bon
mais vous avez contestée d'un gâteau un
point du procès lequel celui où je
n'étais pas là j'étais pas là j'ai des
preuves gt gt à deauville ces quelques
ados qui conduisait la voiture rasées
pour le premier s'est passé pour un des
points qui vous en prochaine en premier
procès oui ce procès où vous risquez du
jour de prison la prison ferme c'est
cela oui oui pour le procès de coups et
blessures vous avez rencontré votre
antagonistes il était là oui moi je n'ai
rien à dire je me serre la main de
personne et vous ni moi je suis tout
pour réussir à la main il m'a pas
regardée pas du tout non bon tu te fais
sont maintenant je pense qu'il est
inutile d'aller plus loin puisqu'il faut
attendre les deux verdicts et nous
suivrons la faire les deux jugements ne
sommes pas racistes